my house is broken because i mean of
course why not yeah right yeah what the
heck works in the house that's what i
want to know broken kitchen broken
everyday everything floor nothing works
yeah and so we found out the heat
it was broken because we turned it on
like you know the first like cold night
i think it was like last week right like
the end of the week he turned it on
that's what broke it we turned the heat
on and the air starts blowing but
it's just air you're gonna love this
house man uh just you know
never turn on
yeah it's working now
but uh don't turn it on just never turn
it on again that's usually what what
breaks it yeah
if you turn it on it's just air blowing
of course and i'm like put my hand up
like i think it's warm
and it's on for like three hours doesn't
do [ __ ] and we wake up a couple a couple
mornings ago and our room was 59 degrees
and kelsey's like
dying and i'm like i'm chilling yeah
yeah i'm fine you kidding me this is
quite regular eh yeah yeah it's actually
quite nice and it's quite nice oh [ __ ]
are you so cold
oh my nuts have shriveled into me buddy
he's right cold so what are you gonna do
just sit in there i gotta get it fixed
yeah a thousand dollars yeah [ __ ] yeah i
had the guy come yesterday run it he
looked at it for like
an hour and was like
yeah i don't know it's not working
though for sure
i was like word
i
look at the thermometer
i can already tell that he's like yeah
i think we just got to replace the whole
thing i was like of course
[Laughter]
of course
let's replace the whole [ __ ] house
yeah i love going through construction
stuff because you just you get to know
guys in capacity that you didn't ask
yeah exactly oh
sick man yeah
you're just like coming downstairs you
like double take oh
yo bro yeah
dope crack man
no i just walk up and i just put my one
finger down
at the top of the crack i'm like nice
dude
he's like swarming there yeah
yeah yeah yeah quite humid yeah
yeah keep it heated up for the clients
i'm surprised you're sweating so much as
it's 59 degrees in here so when you get
down in here it gets hot
yeah when you're doing the work that i
do
trust me you get some swash
you get you typically get hot because
the heater's broken that's what i
figured out is your heater's broken this
way
it's hot down here all the heat is
trapped here so the [ __ ] with the ac
thing right yeah it was leaking mold
whatever got all that fixed now there's
a giant hole in my roof so i got to get
it
patched i gotta get the drywall fixed
right like drywall guy comes
and he's like uh yeah i can i can yeah i
can do this a couple weeks
do you have the paint
like what do you mean the paint he's
like the paint for the roof oh yeah it's
white what do you mean it's drywall it's
like what do you mean no
yeah if we don't have this color then
you gotta repaint the whole roof yep
[ __ ] of course yeah
of course we gotta wear paint though
let's yep let's do the whole [ __ ]
house while we're at it yeah [ __ ] it how
much
yeah million bucks let's do it yeah yo
and i love how um buying paint is like
almost like buying weed it's very you
know like very specific oh yeah like
certain strains yeah just very you know
this paint is more of a body
yeah well the way the way this one was
mixed and grown you know it's just got a
different you know feel to it so yeah
you have to have the exact paint code we
had a similar thing
we you know we had a [ __ ] hole in our
floor and
we we were this close to having to redo
all our floors yeah
dude and it was so funny the guy
you know we're talking about solutions
and our contractor is like well uh
we could just sand down the whole floor
and
try to paint over it you're like
let's burn it down actually yeah yeah
let's burn the whole place down and
we'll rebuild it from scratch that way
we know we're getting everything
yo how
how much is a bulldozer yeah yeah i'll
just i'll clock in i'll just push the
whole thing down and we can start over
it was actually kind of funny um
we go to this flooring place and we're
they have rules about you know regular
civilians aren't allowed inside it was
really vip you know
nice it was pretty it was like it was
trying to like go into the soho house
okay you know this flooring company in
south l.a
you know really it wasn't even south la
it was like the other side of the 110.
we go up in there they're like ah
no
and elena says she does the classic it
it just works everywhere if you're if
you're a lady you can get into any club
oh no my
my friends my do you know my friend and
she name drops our
our contractor and they go oh okay yeah
you're cool they're cool because they
look them up on the list and they're
like he's on our list okay
so then
list of what
contractors yeah just you know sick ass
contracts list of sexy contractors
basically and so
uh
it's we for the hole in our floor we
just need maybe you know 10 or 20 pieces
of wood how big is the hole
i mean it's like [ __ ]
let me think
it's it's probably like 12 feet long and
like six feet wide you're like doing
calculations 200 meters yeah yeah yeah
and so 12 feet long so it's a big hole
it's a big house okay okay you're going
like this so i thought yeah so they you
know uh
but we just need you know little cuts of
wood to like put in and so she basically
she kind of strong arms the dude there
because she she gives them the code for
the for the thing and this is what's
awesome
she hands them the code for the wood and
then they go bring out a piece and it's
like yeah they change the dye
so uh
looks like you're just never gonna get
that that color of wood ever again and
we're like
cool for sure yeah sick yeah
and before i start weeping elena just
she just starts you know she's like you
don't have old boxes go back there and
look if you got some old buck the guy's
like i think we do there's like some
jedi
she's like i think you may have old
boxes he's like i will go back and check
and he goes and he does it and [ __ ]
like
miracle oh there just happened to be
like the exact amount of wood that we
needed
and it it saved us a [ __ ] ton of money
oh man that's so sad that that's like a
good day yeah
yeah how's your day [ __ ] we're
blessed yeah honestly we're [ __ ]
blessed yeah the guy in the back had the
extra wood boxes and now we don't have
oh
it's a beautiful day what a time to be
alive truly once we finally put the wood
in everything matched the whole house
collapsed
we took one seat on the couch we're like
it's finally done
i i think unless you become really
spiritual or you have
a billion dollars nothing
is really ever that
perfect yeah yep yeah that's a good
point
that's a really good point guys i was
complaining about this to my friend he's
like it's just every place yeah
everything every apartment that you've
had or anything everything always breaks
all the time yeah it's just nice when
you have someone to call and be like hey
can you like if you live in an apartment
building or whatever and you're like hey
this thing broke and they're like cool
and someone else deals with it but that
assumes you have a good landlord yeah
exactly yeah
because you know landlords are yeah
[ __ ] people aka people
yeah when people call me about the
apartment complex i'm running in a
decentraland yes i hang up that discord
call so quick yeah
i'm like
you know it's like boom boom boom yellow
the toilet has been being weird in my
decentraland place like once every
couple flushes it'll just stay running i
can't get it to stop yeah reach in there
okay i'll see what i can do it's uh it's
just uh you know the pipes and the city
it's all
let me call my guy you know i'll i'll
i'll call you back in give me 10 minutes
i'll call you back 10 minutes okay 10
minutes okay all right the pipes you
said yeah
okay
and i don't call them back
you